- Perhaps someday in the far future
we'll be telling our grandkids
about how restaurants
once had human servers.
Instead of ordering
from a kiosk or a phone
a flesh and blood employee would come
to your table, offer
recommendations, and take your order.
So old fashioned, right?
- Yes, it seems like many
of the food service
technologies popularized
during the pandemic are sticking around.
Even though the majority
of Americans are vaccinated
and we've largely gone back
to eating maskless indoors,
we're still scanning QR codes
and scrolling through digital menus.
Why is that?
- Of course, COVID is still with us
and still poses a threat
to vulnerable people
but we now know that you're
far more likely to get it
from the air than a piece of paper.
The reason we haven't reverted back
to pre-pandemic dining
trends has less to do
with epidemiology or even
technology than economics.
Specifically labor economics.
(upbeat music)
- It's been called The Great Resignation,
The Great Renegotiation,
or The Great Reshuffle
and it refers to an unprecedented spike
in Americans voluntarily
leaving their jobs beginning
in early 2021.
At first, some politicians
were quick to accuse people
of being lazy, opting to
live off government handouts
rather than work for a living.
But as the picture became
clear, economists found
that most quitters were
not leaving the workforce--
they were looking for a better job.
- And for a lot of them it worked.
In many regions, workforce
participation is back up
to or even higher than
it was pre-pandemic.
Wages have risen
virtually across the board
although inflation has
taken a chunk out of that
and many workers find
that they have more power
and flexibility at their
jobs than they did before.
- However, there are a few
sectors still struggling
to fill vacant positions,
and hospitality is at
the top of that list.
As of the summer of 2022,
food service employment
is still 6% below pre-pandemic levels.
There are two big reasons:
as non-essential businesses,
many restaurants closed their doors
at the beginning of the pandemic.
Since their employees were some
of the first to be laid off or furloughed
they were also the first to find new jobs,
many in burgeoning sectors
like tech and logistics.
When the restaurant industry
finally started to come back
they found that their employees
didn't want to... come back.
- That leads us to the second big reason.
These jobs were never
that good to begin with.
Low pay, unpredictable schedules,
lack of benefits and
advancement potential.
Many of the people who used
to work in the food service
industry prefer their new jobs more,
quoting higher pay and flexibility
as the most important factors.
- But wait, if these jobs were so lousy,
why did it take a pandemic
for cooks and servers to
finally leave the apron behind?
- The short answer is that
the labor market is much
tighter now due to several factors.
Not everyone who quit found another job.
Some started their own businesses,
some went back to school.
A lot of baby boomers saw the pandemic
as a good time to retire,
taking their decades of
work experience with them.
Gen-Zers have less interest
in food service as a temporary job
and more restrictive
immigration policies have
meant less migrant labor as well.
The cumulative result is that there aren't
enough applicants to fill
all the available positions,
giving workers more leverage and choice.
- That's great for workers,
but rough for the industry
and it creates a destructive spiral.
Short staffed restaurants
ask their employees
to work harder.
Customers are less satisfied,
giving more complaints and fewer tips.
As the job becomes less worth it
more people quit and
the problem gets worse.
- Employers are aware of the dilemma
and many are putting their faith
in technology as the magic solution.
QR codes, online menus, phone
payments, robot servers--
anything that can cut down the number
of humans on staff is being implemented.
There are even some
artificial intelligence
technologies being
developed that can, say,
understand a customer's spoken
order at a drive-through
or predict what ingredients to order
from vendors to minimize food waste.
According to one survey, more than 75%
of eateries now use at
least three automated tools.
And the restaurant
management software market
is expected to grow
by almost 16% annually
over the next decade.
- But not everyone is on board.
Some food service
employees say that working
alongside tech makes the
job harder, not easier.
Not all customers have smartphones
and some that do aren't
comfortable navigating technology.
Servers often have to play
the role of tech support
and may receive smaller
tips from irritated diners.
Mobile ordering also
encourages customers to
make more additions and special requests
while expecting machine-like
speed and accuracy.
Servers and baristas who
once prided themselves
on their interpersonal skills now feel
like dehumanized vending machines.
- It's not very pleasant
for the customers either.
A study done by social
psychologist Ryan Dwyer
found that cell phone use
during social interactions
like shared meals
decreased the enjoyment of
the experience for everyone.
And we all know that using
your phone for one thing,
like ordering a drink
can easily spiral into checking your email
replying to texts, and
scrolling through Insta.
- There are other unforeseen consequences
of restaurant tech.
Many of these automated systems
like the rest of the internet,
collect data about you
and your eating habits and
share it with advertisers.
Some industry experts see a future where
your menu is tailored specifically
to you with prices that
fluctuate depending on
what's available or nearing expiration.
While it could be handy to have a menu
that remembers your food allergies,
surge pricing for meals has been met
with pretty fierce backlash
where it's been tried.
Imagine seeing your steak dinner go
on sale right after
you finished eating it.
- Besides eating out isn't just
about acquiring a meal as
efficiently as possible.
If that's your priority,
you're better off ordering in.
As we said in a previous video
you're paying not just for
food, but an environment
in which you can have
meaningful human interactions.
Some restaurateurs still believe
that the classic dining experience is what
customers are looking
for, and the only way to
save it is to make the
jobs more attractive
to prospective and current employees.
- That can mean paying higher wages
allowing more flexible schedules
and offering benefits and perks.
But at a time when 53% of
Americans have already cut back
on dining out when food costs are up
by 17% and 41% of restaurants
can't even afford the rent
where will they get the
money to pay employees more?
Some are raising their prices
others shrinking their menus
or shortening their hours.
And many say that investing
in an experienced staff is
actually more cost effective.
Turnover is expensive.
You can end up spending more
on training and recruitment than
on the perks it would take
to retain valuable employees.
- No one knows what will
happen to the industry
but the next couple years are
likely to be transformative.
Perhaps dining in the future will be
like stepping into an
automated vending machine
or maybe careers in food
service will finally
get the respect and
compensation they deserve.
Or a potential recession could erode
labor's bargaining power
and restaurants will go
back to business as usual.
- Like most economics,
it's a question of values.
How much do diners value
the traditional restaurant experience?
How much do employers
value their employees?
- And how much do we
all value face-to-face
human connections?
And that's our our 2 cents.
- [Host] Thanks to our patrons
for keeping 2 Cents financially healthy.
Click the link
in the description to
become a 2 Cents patron.
- For more on how the pandemic
affected small businesses
check out our video,
"Can the Food Service
Industry Survive Coronavirus?"
(soft music)